[Music]
Everything went according to the scenario
I tried to create the best game I
can't imitate anyone,
I'm the representative of originality that no one can imitate I am the
creator, but
in front of the creator of this world itself,
everything is different.  In fiction, everyone is just a
happy mob who lives and dies in the role they've been given,
but I've been chosen differently.To be the
designer of a new world and your
playable character.How about
my scenario?
Enjoy!  I'm happy for you. I wonder if it'll
do well Final
Club
[Applause]
[Music]
Congratulations,
you guys were born now
Magical girls
[Music]
Magical Destroyers